[Musique]
voici à quoi ressemble de nombreuses
scènes de combat en Ukraine des drones
attaquent des véhicules ou lancent des
grenades dans les trancher et les abris
de
l'ennemi les drones kamikas portent les
caméras les moins chers parce qu'ils ne
reviennent
pas les doigts doivent agir avec
souplesse et
précision
contr ces pilotes de drone s'entraînent
en guise de une bouteille
d'eau ce ne sont pas des munitions
standard no les Fabri même c'est une
bombe artisanale à manipuler avec
beaucoup de précaution on enlève la
goupille et 30 secondes après la bombe
est
active vu l'Ance de savoiriloter des
drones l'armée a cré des unités
spéciales avant l'armée ukrainienne
n'avait pas d'unité dédié uniquement aux
attaques de
drone mais aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
s'en passer chaque brigade chaque
bataillon possède une telle
unité et on plus à partir à
l'assut depuis leur base zaporidia la
capitale régionale ces hommes peuvent
suivre les combats en temps réel grâce à
des drones de
surveillance
apparu dans le courant de cette guerre
la possibilité de voir ce qui se passe
tout au long de la ligne de front c'est
vraiment bien cela nous permet
d'analyser le comportement de l'ennemi
dans toutes les
directions zat et son frère ont un
atelier où il fabrique répare et
améliore des drones de toutes
sortes mon frère met tout son cœur dans
chacun de ces drones c'est vrai qu'on un
pincement au cœur de les fabriquer à la
main puis de les envoyer pour un vol
sans retour ce truc est formidable il
coûte 600 dollars chacun à
fabriqué pendant un certain temps
l'industrie des drones ukrainiennes
avait une longueur d'avance sur celle
des Russes mais plus
maintenant ils nous ont rattrapé et même
dépassé sur le front leurs drones
kamikaz sont un immense problème pour
nous pour pouvoir les éviter nga doivent
laisser leur véhicule loin de leur
position et marcher parfois pendant
plusieurs heures avec ses drones kamikaz
audessus de le
[Musique]
tête selon les observateurs la Russie
produirait aujourd'hui si fois plus de
drone à transmission vidéo en temps réel
que l'Ukraine un cauchemar pour ceux
dans leur ligne de mire à l'atelier cet
autre combattant vient soumettre un
problème technique il arrive tout droit
d'un village situé sur la ligne de
front il n'y a quasiment plus aucun
bâtiment debout il n a que des ruines
mais heureusement chaque village
ukrainien les gens creusent des
sous-sols donc on vit sous terre et on
pilote les drones depuis ces sous-sols
la plupart du temps on y va quand il
fait nuit et on en sort quand il fait
nuit
aussi le drone que bourgeois vient faire
réparer est produit par l'un des
fabricants nationaux de ce secteur en
plein
essort depuis notre position on avait un
groupe de troupes ennemies à notre
portée on voulait leur jeter des bombes
mais malheureusement le système de
l'argage n'a pas fonctionné c'était
vraiment très frustrant mais ça va être
réparé
maintenant leur verdict sur l'industrie
foisonnante des drones en Ukraine peut
mieux faire il y a beaucoup de
producteurs de drones FPV mais ce n'est
pas organisé ça ne se développe pas il
faudrait structurer tout ça au niveau de
l'État c'est précisément ce que l'État
ukrainien tente de faire à travers son
programme de test de certification et de
financement intitulé armée de drone ces
spécialistes testent la résistance
Brouage le brouillage c'est vraiment là
où tout se joue aujourd'hui c'est
pourquoi nous changeons constamment nos
systèmes de communication et nos
fréquences en Ukraine la production de
drone n'est pas centralisé l'état
coordonne le secteur privé et fait la
liaison avec
l'armée il n'y a pas une société
publique qui produit tout en série nous
travaillons tous différemment et c'est
pourquoi nous sommes très dur à
battreousons
et nous uons différ systmes de
communication et de navigation c'est un
vrai
avantage l'Ukraine compte aujourd'hui
plus de 200 sociétés qui produisent des
drones la plupart sont petites
spécialisé dans les hautes technologies
chez Skylab ont fait des drones volants
et aussi cet appareil au sol le Circo
S1 cela évite à nos soldats de risquer
leur vie ils peuvent rester à l'abri et
envoyer cet appareil pour transporter
par exemple des armes
le cirin peut aussi poser des mines
antichar mais pour ce qui est de son
drone vetteen attend depuis plus d'un an
sa certification par
l'État nous avons besoin d'un produit
qui soit développé et produit en masse
en
Ukraine seul les commandes d'État
peuvent garantir le développement d'une
société je pense que la bureaucratie
mine cet effort ou bien des individus
isolés au sein de chaî de
décision la production et l'acquisition
de Dron augmente mais pas encore assez
pour couvrir les
besoins